it's hard to take the shinola out of
Detroit or Detroit out of shine oh look
at a time where most factories are
closing we're building a factory this is
a city that really knows how and likes
to make things what we've done is built
a watch that really is meant to be with
you for the rest of your life the
components that we use in our products
well very similar to some of our
competition where our competition would
charge 2,000 or 3,000 dollars we charge
six hundred to a thousand dollars the
idea here is to create a product that is
a wonderful design great quality and
good value people don't mind paying for
something they understand is made by
people that care people are willing to
pay for that our manufacturing manager
here Paloma she comes to us from Louie
Vuitton so she comes to us with you know
decades of experience
we sort of put the craftspeople front
and center we give them a lovely place
to work we talk about them and we share
their stories with people I didn't have
a manufacturing background I didn't know
nothing about watches and for the last
two years I don't know a lot about
watches amazing I never thought that I
will meet the formal or any president
and my life whatever amazing feeling I
was very honored today there are six
product categories and obviously shoe
polish which is the heritage of the
company because of the design because of
the DNA that is built into every one of
the products they all flow together last
year we assembled almost 50,000 watches
we sold out all those 50,000 this year
we look to triple that amount and at the
moment we are barely keeping up with
demand we really believe that there's
great growth potential we're in this
business to be a successful business
which means that we want to be a
profitable business our business
continues to grow exponentially and
we're very excited where we are at this
very early stage
Oh